hey guys anna welcome back to the layah heilpern
show this is a special so i'm really excited to
announce that i'm doing an ama with block fi so
joining me today on behalf of blockbuy is shane
mullen shane great to have you how are you doing
today hey leah i'm doing great thanks for having
me yeah it's a pleasure i'm super excited um
because we had celsius on um a couple weeks ago
so i think it's only right to have you guys on um
and kind of just provide the audience with as much
information as possible about the best places
they can go to earn interest on their crypto so
are you ready sounds sounds great okay great so
for those that don't know anything about blockfy
um just tell us about it how did you get
started um and also where does the name
come from it's quite an interesting one yeah
it's a couple really great questions leia so um
starting with kind of the evolution of the
business back in 2017 zac prince our co-founder
bought a ton of bitcoin had a substantial you know
ethereum litecoin a couple other positions and
with the meteoric rise of the price of bitcoin
rather than wanting to sell his position and earn
liquidity in that capacity he was looking for an
alternative way to unlock liquidity on his assets
so what's the best way to unlock liquidity on a
pool of assets well traditionally in the equity
markets you can margin lend and borrow against the
value of your portfolio so zach went out to the
bunch of banks that he had known and a bunch of
fintechs and was looking for liquidity or a loan
backed by his bitcoin uh and it didn't exist
and that was the impetus for the business right
creating uh crypto backed loans uh collateralized
by the cryptocurrencies that we support today
um that business grew really quickly in 2017
2018 uh and then shortly thereafter zach and
flory who's our other co-founder realized that
not only is lending which is one financial service
uh within you know the broader kind of fintech
ecosystem available or should be available for
crypto investors but other financial services
products should be available as well right things
like an interest account where you can earn yield
on your crypto things like trading or buying and
selling things like credit uh and the list goes on
uh and so the business today if you fast forward
has evolved into a full suite financial services
system platform for the crypto investor um and the
name funny enough it's uh i want to say and zack's
probably going to say you're wrong on this one but
i want to say it's a play on sofi right so far is
social finance block fi is blockchain finance so
block fi is what it's short for okay interesting
so i guess you know you guys wanted to provide
something different um and like you said you
interest is obviously a huge one for you guys and
something that i always tend to ask um because
it's something that i can't even myself wrap
my head around is the interest right so you know
interest levels are basically interest rates are
basically flat right i mean particularly in the
uk we saw negative interest rates across europe
um so when i try and tell my friends actually
my brother is a fantastic example you know i'm
turning around and i'm like you need to sign up
with these accounts you can get all this interest
it's really hard to explain where this
comes from and how you're able to do that
if traditional banks aren't able to do that
so i actually have i think i think i deposited
like 500 or something with you guys um in
usdc and i get up to 8.6 percent interest
so how on earth are you doing this yeah it's a
great question so you know similar to the way
that a bank operates with its deposits right where
it will take any of our dollars that we put into a
checking account and then repurpose and lend them
out to institutional clients we do the exact same
thing with cryptocurrency so if you put your usdc
or your gusd or bitcoin ethereum into a block by
interest account we are actually lending that
those funds out to institutional counterparties
who are borrowing against or borrowing from block
fi at you know rates that are meaningful uh where
we're able to pass down some of that yield onto
our uh depositors um which would be our retail
clients like yourself um so through our massive
today which has grown probably 5x since i started
five months ago uh institutional desk we're
able to capture very significant yields in a
very sustainable way okay so this question is kind
of just off the top of my head why don't you think
banks are doing this if it's so simple if it's
so easy and you know plenty of crypto companies
are doing it what's the problem oh man i have a
long long laundry list of items why that's not
the case but i think just in general look like at
the end of the day we're still very early innings
in what we're doing here within the crypto space
um there aren't many institutional lenders uh
because institutional lenders have not been in
the space long enough to understand some of the
risks associated or how to underwrite or how to
properly manage a large portfolio of crypto assets
and i think banks in general right don't and
will not in the short term be able to support
some of the financial services type
products that we can support today because
they just simply don't understand how
these assets work and they do not have the
rules and and systems built to support the scale
and the speed in which you need to operate in
this environment so i think you'll start to see
banks slowly enter into space more in the form
of a custody like relationship but when we talk
about customer facing financial services products
and institutional facing financial services
products i think it's going to take a while
i think you know you mentioned banks getting
into the space as you know custodians and
and i think that's so funny because when the you
know when banks announce that they can now hold
your crypto or i think it was the u.s regulatory
authorities sort of said you know we give the
green light for this i thought that was so funny
i just really did i thought it was hilarious um
but anyway so like i said we did have celsius on
a couple of weeks ago so you know they are one
of your main competitors so for those that don't
know tell me how are you guys different to them
yeah i mean look you know uh we see celsius
all the time um you know to give you an idea
of you know where we sit we're u.s based new
york city uh new jersey headquartered a lot of
folks in new york a lot of folks in in the in
the u.s we've got offices across five different
countries 350 employees um we're regulated
uh at the federal level uh money services
business license and then we're regulated at
the state level money transmitter licenses
as well as lending licenses in every state that
we operate in um we never launched an ico we don't
have a utility token we've raised all our money
from institutional capital folks like susquehanna
peter thiel coinbase ventures the winklevoss about
100 million to date uh series c was 50 million
and that's what the funds that we use to
operate our business and so then you know
because we don't have a utility token right all
the yield that's generated to pay our clients is
directly correlated to the institutional demand
that we have on the lending portfolio on that
side of the house um uh so that i would say the
few things there are a little bit different yeah
the utility token is a huge one um you know
particularly when it comes to earning that
interest and getting it back so do you ever have
any plans to get to sort of launch utility token
we don't have any plans no not not to my knowledge
um if anything we are firm believers in stable
coin uh and that you know this market will
actually be it will grow exponentially by sheer
nature of being able to interact and pay with
stable coins so um more stable coin adoption more
currency adoption would be kind of the first angle
we would take if any if anything for next year
okay so i want to kind of go into the questions
that was submitted those are just a couple ones
that were just off the top of my head that
um i wanted to check with you guys but um in
terms of tax because tax is such a huge issue
when it comes to crypto and it has this sort of
um you know negative dirty connotation
particularly bitcoin you know people think that
it's all about um money laundering and tax evasion
and that's obviously just not the case um so one
of the questions actually submitted is will there
be any integration with tax services um like coin
tracker for example yeah it's a great question
um i've had a ton of really unique conversations
with a lot of different tax providers who
are building great solutions for this space
totally agree with you this is look an area
where more investment more buying and selling
more taxable events are going to lead to just
tools that need to be created to help manage and
monitor more taxable events i also think that as
we grow and as we scale this industry right there
will be a bit more of a microscope on what's
happening within our space and we want to make
sure we're doing everything compliantly we want
to make sure that we're doing everything under the
regulatory framework that is correct tax i believe
is going to be a big part of that we do have plans
to integrate with a tax provider um it's not
you know fully launched yet so i don't want to
name names um but we are going to also be looking
into building some external reporting apis in you
know the early half of next year so that anybody
who's a block by customer that uses a tax service
you know externally whichever country they that
supports them or that they decide to use would
be able to pull their information in in real time
or at least close to real time um but as of today
uh we are not live we will be live i want
to say in a couple weeks so stay tuned for
uh some of the news on our website okay that's
great so it's coming basically yeah it's coming
all right great so another question for
you guys is block five profitable yet
yeah so uh we as a business right
from a health perspective are uh
on a tear uh the the best way for me to
give you an idea of where we sit i started
five months ago we were 150 employees uh
we were doing eight figures of revenue
uh we had about 1.5 billion assets on the
platform and bitcoin was trading at about 10k
five months ago today we're about 380
employees across five countries we've got
nine figures of revenue three uh point one
i believe as of today billion assets on the
platform and bitcoins trading almost at all-time
highs honestly it might we might see history on
this call right now i don't i don't know that
would be that'd be pretty remarkable but do you
know what you're right i actually i'm just going
to jump in i actually need to check the price
of bitcoin while we're here we're we are we are
approaching a historical moment in time um 19.3
it could happen on the cool if it does then that
is just great and we'll we'll celebrate somehow
you know i might have to run and go find a bottle
of wine grab a drink or something keep this back
we all need to celebrate and then uh this just
that's the floor for the for the you know next
however many of years that we hit all-time
highs which i think will be a very long time
oh i'm excited so we're getting actually
quite a few questions coming through so i'll
i'll go i'll answer these ones first and
then i'll answer the ones coming through
um okay so here's an interesting one for you why
does it take so long to transfer out so somebody
actually told me that they um that it took
them 36 hours to transfer i think it was usdc
to kraken so they said it's really easy to get
the money in but they're struggling to get the
money out so that's a bit concerning what's going
on yeah we have a couple resources on the website
that actually talk about various specifics on when
you withdraw what time of day and when the funds
are going to land in your account we have a hold
period uh it's typically before 5 pm eastern so i
think the 36 hour issue is could be an outlayer
but um there are moments where folks deposit or
withdraw sorry withdraw after five on a weekend
you know sometimes it's delayed in that capacity
but really shouldn't see anything in that uh of
that length um and you know all of our withdrawal
information is online um we also have some fees
regarding withdrawals they're pretty low 25 cents
for usdc and gsd um even lower for other cryptos
but all that information yeah is readily available
i'm happy to uh shoot some links over after this
to share with your community okay that sounds
great i think that's probably the best thing to
do then um just check out those withdrawal times
um but look i would say you know at least
you're getting money out it's not crashing
and everything is running smoothly um because i
think we're always seeing whenever borons happen
certain companies seem to crash so it's good that
we're you're staying afloat for the minute um this
one's interesting actually because you know of
course interest is a huge one for you guys so
can't block if i actually add graphs and stats
so people can actually track their development
and see how things are going yeah a hundred
percent so um i currently have the beta uh you
know blockfy account which is awesome uh so i get
to see all the cool stuff that's coming out before
our clients do um but we are going to be releasing
market prices so being able to see the pricing um
directly in uh in the app which is huge and then
uh charting functionality performance statistics
uh just being able to look at you know hit
performance over time these are all things
that are going to be coming within the ui
come early next year what i would really like
encourage anyone on here listening who's
interested in those types of statistics is to just
dm block fi's in twitter handle and throw your
feedback in we love to see customer feedback of
what people would think would be valuable um what
types of tools that they'd be interested in using
um so if you have any ideas shoot them over
that's the best way for us to prioritize what
we build for our community yeah i think you know
having these kind of graphs are so important
especially when you're trying to because we were
chatting earlier before we went live and we were
sort of saying you know when you're trying to
convince people to join crypto and join the
revolution all the stuff and if you're trying
to show them these interest rates like you know
saying about my brother i was trying to show him
these interest rates it'll be fantastic to have
that graph and just be like look at my portfolio
look what's happened um so yeah that's good and i
think um that's really great to hear that you know
the community can reach out to you and sort of say
oh i'd like to see this or when's that coming
um so yeah i i think that's really important um
i want to talk about insurance and and things
like that so let's start with um credit forward so
how do you guys actually protect against credit
for type um instances yeah i mean one of the main
principles and drivers of building our business
when we as we built it in as we continue to build
is concept of risk management right and risk
management is really you know how do we prevent
losses because at the end of the day we're a
financial services business and we're in the
business of making sure people money is secure
safe and it appreciates over time right um
our chief risk officer he is uh comes from the
equity derivatives world so he's built many
businesses that have zero losses providing margin
lending or lending against portfolios of equities
right so it's very similar to the way that
our book works today any of the loans that we
originate on the institutional side a majority
of them are over collateralized meaning that
if a company wants to if an institution wants to
borrow usdc or gusd they have to post collateral
bitcoin ethereum litecoin etc and we have access
to that and we have access to sell that collateral
in the event that something a price swings in one
way or the other right so we're protected on that
side on top of that our kyc and underwriting
process is quite rigorous for an institution
that wants to borrow from blockfy we ask for
financials bank statements we ask for everything
that you would think of when you're looking
to get a loan as an institution anywhere else
as well as aml and kyc materials that we
can make sure that these companies are real
right and they're not fraudulent and they don't
have you know significant issues in the market
with other potential uh partners or players or
fintechs or crypto firms et cetera right so i
would say the risk management layer on top of the
over collateralization of our institutional loans
plus our rigorous underwriting and ability to
not even fund unless we have all these details
really really create a solid barrier right and a
solid uh risk uh profile for you know who we work
with and how we operate in this space um i will
say when uh we've seen five 25 price swings here
at block fight just by nature of us starting
business 2017 march of this year was a huge
swing we've experienced uh perfect performance
for our customers right meaning zero losses uh
on the book so you know it's a testament to their
this our risk management team it's a testament to
security it's a testament to building the business
with this you know margin component in mind um
and you know it's something that we're we're very
proud of and that we want our our customers to
understand that their their money is is willing
to work and be safe and low risk at block by
so with that all in mind you know every day this
is crypto this is still really immature market
um companies are still very new every day we
hear you know really reputable companies going
bust or whatever and or getting hacked or ceos
running off with keys and all that fun stuff um
so in terms of insurance what are you insured and
also how much are you insured up to what happens
in a situation whereby number one you can't pay
enough interest that or you can't pay the interest
that you know you guys promise or number two
um you just don't have the money to give people
back when they you know when they want to take
the money um off your platform bit like a bank
run or something like that sure um so cup couple
things in that question i can dice apart the first
insurance so today blockfi does not have direct
insurance for our customers but we do custody
uh all our assets with gemini and bitco uh and
gemiini and bitco do have insurance plans um i
would refer to their websites to read up a little
bit more on how big how much but it's important to
understand that uh them as a custody provider uh
you know best the business time tested in terms of
losses in the concept of you know will block if
i never be able to pay me my interest et cetera
um couple things to think about the first is
over collateralization on the institutional
book right you have institutional borrowers that
are driving all the yield on our platform if the
price of bitcoin as an example goes from 19k to 4k
we have margin calls built in so that we actually
can sell right that bitcoin to cover our retail
clients interest before it gets to a price that's
going to be unsustainable for our business right
very important to understand right you're giving
as an institution us at the actual collateral and
it's ours right um and if something happens to the
price or they run away and they disappear or they
go out of business or whatever it is we have that
over collateralization right which means you know
uh over a hundred percent of the value of the loan
we have in the form of of assets
so that's a huge protection
huge some of the other players in the
space you guys have heard of that have
potentially or or have gone under um under
collateralization is probably something that they
supported in majority meaning the amount of
crypto or collateral that you give me right
uh is less than the amount of the loan notional
that i give you right so if the price drops
there's a there's a piece in there that i
don't i don't have the ability to make up for
very very risky um in my mind personally and
our company thinks the same way um lastly
you know if any catastrophic event were to happen
black swan um you'd face block fight as a business
we've raised a hundred million of equity um and
you know we are very very strong and healthy from
a balance sheet perspective so um of anyone in the
space of anywhere to be we are the place um from
uh from a risk perspective because we actually do
have a question i'm gonna put it up on the screen
um so what would happen to user funds if block
fight got hacked so that's kind of a bit of a
follow-up question if you can answer that for us
yeah so i mean security measures first of all is
something that we believe in wholeheartedly just
as high i would say number two to risk management
um we recently hired the cso from uh backed
his name's adam healy he's built a team of
dozens of security engineers and and security
professionals that come from the likes of
kpmg deloitte uh but then other you know crypto
native firms so uh from a hack perspective we're
well positioned right to to be uh ahead
of anything that might come to fruition um
you know in the event that something happened
again i think got to go back to this concept of
uh we do have a incredibly strong
balance sheet we're well positioned to
make sure that if something did happen
our customers would be covered uh in the
capacity that we can cover them um and that's
really important i think because you know
our our balance sheet is so powerful
right and our risk management system is so
uh it operates with uh i would say rigor uh and
and little flaw coupled right with the security
concept of in the security aspect of you know
how we've built this this that side of the house
it's a it's a very secure environment for in my
capacity okay um i want to move on a little bit um
and i want to talk about a potential credit card
so is that on its way um and with that in mind
actually um something like crypto.com you know
they they provide interest and they have a card
so do you guys see yourselves as a competitor
or someone similar in that in that respect
yeah man i love when the credit card conversation
gets brought up because it's so exciting
um most of the folks who uh listen to your show
leia and honestly block fight followers or not
you may have may not heard that we are going
to be launching a bitcoin rewards credit card
in q1 of of 2021 um and it's gonna be a visa card
right it's got a really sweet logo i'm not gonna
tell anybody what it looks like quite
yet um and you're gonna be able to spend
um your credit card fiat at merchants and
earn one point five percent back in bitcoin
that's good when it's going to get deposited
in your block by interest account and
your bitcoin's going to start earning
interest as you receive it as you redeem
so we think that you know as a business uh
our customers predominantly uh prefer to
hold their bitcoin and earn interest on it versus
spend it so we figure why not spend fiat credit
and then have that credit get converted into
bitcoin rewards so a lot of interesting demand
and uh excited to launch that okay just a
question on that fiat credit then can you
just clarify where's that fiat money coming from
so how is that card getting topped up like can we
go for it it's like any other credit card
that you would get at a bank right it's uh
it's created by our card partner and then you get
a limit right say your limit's five thousand bucks
you spend five thousand dollars worth of credit
via the bank that supports our card and then of
that five thousand dollars we multiply 1.5 at
the end of the month and you get that amount in
bitcoin then you just got to pay the card back
like you would any other card in your wallet oh
sorry i missed you so it's a credit card right
it's not debit sorry sorry so there's no topping
up um no topping up whatsoever you pay it back
yeah yeah just just like your standard card and
i think it why did you choose that option that's
quite interesting yeah i think it goes to like
this narrative that um you know we want to bridge
the gap between traditional financial services and
crypto right and i think uh being able to use a
credit or for like a form of payment in the form
of credit and earn bitcoin back is a really good
way to enter the market for a lot of people um and
it's also a good way to you know earn an asset
that you don't necessarily want to spend some
people don't want to spend their bitcoin yeah i
think that's interesting um um i'll definitely try
that out i'd like to try everything out um i'm a
big fan of of crypto cards um i think i have like
three which is actually too many if you
think about it actually there's actually
too many and i kind of want to try more to
be honest so i'll definitely give that a go
we've got some uh some great news coming out on uh
next week you'll see uh around a waitlist and uh
you'll be able to see what the card looks like it
i think when you see it you're gonna want it and
to have it and use it because that matters right
like on a really shallow level that matters you
know it's like i wanna i wanna go to a restaurant
and drop my you know block fight card on the table
you know and is it plastic or is it going
to be metal can we just can we get that info
yeah we're we're debating i think a beginning run
will be there'll be like a limited time offer of
metal and then we might uh you know be a different
material but still in the works um all of that
yeah like if you join the wait list and you move
up on the waitlist by referring people you get
a chance to get the medal card so that's a
nice perk there you go um which if any assets
will be added so i actually don't know what are
you missing right now which assets don't you have
yeah you know i this is a this is a great question
because so many people write in and so many folks
ask us about borrowing in certain assets and
then also just earning yield on a lot of assets
i think you're going to see you know between
two and five new assets get added to block fi
by the end of q1 of 2021 those assets are going
to be assets that have uh that predominantly been
in the top 10 market cap if not top 20. um okay
and and mostly all existing you know have been
around for you know the last handful of years
and have some significant market cap to them so
yeah makes sense okay so here's a question um
specifically from me um so given bitcoin is
just running right now my dms are flooded my dm's
are just like wow can i get in where can i get in
no no no no no all that fun stuff um so you know
my i have quite a few favorite platforms and you
know i think you guys are a reputable company
so you're one of the people that i would like
to suggest but i can't because you don't allow
people to actually buy crypto with fiat right so
i know that you can buy let's say bitcoin with um
usdt but that's unhelpful for those who don't have
any crypto whatsoever they don't have stable coins
so when are you actually going to provide going to
provide some actual serious direct on-wraps
and off-ramps actually yeah so the way that
our on-ramps work today and i can explain it um
it's actually very simple and straightforward so
uh we have one method of moving fiat onto uh the
platform that's via a wire so you can wire your
local fiat directly from your bank account into
your block by interest account and that will
purchase usdt if you're you know abroad or it will
purchase gusd or usdc depending on what you want
to select um let's say ten thousand dollars you
wire into the platform just for example purposes
uh you will have a balance of 10 000 gusd in like
two hours right because wires move pretty quickly
yeah as soon as you have that balance in
your platform you've deposited those funds
and converted to gusd you could buy bitcoin
immediately but do you have to convert it to
gsd or were you saying that as soon as you wire it
it's automatically done or you actually have to do
that today you have to wire in for gusd and then
go in and purchase the bitcoin um we all also are
releasing actually today the ability to ach
funds onto the platform as well in the same
capacity which is a little bit easier than wiring
right because with ach all you do is just connect
your bank account uh and then that's it you can
push money on whatever you want takes i think two
to three business days to land um but yeah in the
future there will be the ability to just directly
buy it have that have that kind of like conversion
piece the gusd to bitcoin piece happen instantly
today though it's just wire in log in buy bitcoin
now you own bitcoin you're immediately earning
interest on that bitcoin six percent is what we
pay today but i just want to clarify because maybe
i'm not getting it maybe i'm being ridiculous but
when you wire in your fear are you saying that
it automatically lands in gusd it automatically
lands in whichever you sell whichever stable coin
you select yeah oh usdc usdt if you're abroad
and what's cool about the wire and the automatic
land is as soon as that those funds land in
your account and are converted to stablecoin
you earn 8.6 on stablecoin on our platform right
well there you go so your money's always earning
interest no matter where it is on block fi which
is really cool okay so just finally because we're
approaching half an hour to wrap up our ama um
what is gonna look like for you guys what is
going on um it's been a wild year um everything
with the coronavirus it seems that it hasn't
really affected our industry that much given how
decentralized everything is so that's really great
um but yeah with that in mind you know we don't
know what's going on with the korean virus in 2021
what does 2021 look like for you guys um any new
updates coming i know you mentioned the card and
so on yeah i mean we've got a ton of new really
big important hires we're bringing on a new cfo
um in the end of this month uh we're probably
going to double the team next year just
based by sheer uh you know hiring needs and where
we're adding folks already it's pretty remarkable
we'll be launching some new products more
specifically enhancing right trading functionality
enhancing some of the visualizations on the ui
enhancing some of the onboarding and fiat on
ramps as well as you just mentioned leia and
then really focusing a lot of our efforts on
the credit card because we really do think
this credit card could be you know a huge
uh push for the industry bringing on you know
traditionally crypto curious folks who are now
you know using a card and earning bitcoin um and
there's just you know so many cool avenues of of
partnerships exploration bd growth that you can
do with something along those lines but um i'm
really looking forward to 2021. i think the crypto
market is only going to go up and to the right the
amount of adoption that we've seen is unbelievable
institutional and retail as you've seen it as well
um yeah i i joke with with my girlfriend like
she's like constantly asking me what i'm doing
on my phone and i say i'm reading crypto twitter
i can't get out of it it's addictive there's too
much good hype it's uh it's too exciting it's too
funny the memes are too good the new number yeah
yeah exactly yeah i encourage anybody who's uh
listening during thanksgiving if they have uh
you know or or holidays wherever you are if you're
with the family and you're talking about bitcoin
to uh to help uh educate them the best way you
can i've already had to have a couple educating
conversations there you go that's so funny yeah i
mean it is crazy the amount of people that we're
seeing getting it getting into bitcoin i think
just recently within an hour the other day i think
25 000 new bitcoin addresses were made in one hour
which is the highest since the previous bull run
yeah yeah so yeah i'm so excited um but
yeah shane i want to thank you so much
it's been really great um hearing all of this
um doing the ama with you so thank you so much
for coming on awesome lay i really appreciate
it thanks for being a great partner as well
yeah absolutely pleasure guys definitely don't
forget to tune in on thursday because i have a
really cool guest i'll tell you now cz is coming
on the show so it's going to be so much fun guys
so make sure you tune in on thursday it will
be at 12 p.m est so i will see you all then bye
bye